l'europe et particulièrement les voisins
de l'union soviétique sont très inquiet
bien sûr de la progression de ce nuage
radioactif dont la teneur restent pour
le moment sans danger ce matin le
service central de protection contre les
radiations ionisantes a annoncé une
légère hausse de la radioactivité
atmosphérique non significative pour la
santé publique dans le sud est de la
france et plus spécialement au dessus de
monaco la progression du nuage
radioactif détail et maintenant par
laurent bouvier
voici la situation telle quelle et se
présentait en début de semaine un
anticyclone centré sur le cren et autour
duquel les masses d'air tournent dans le
sens des aiguilles d'une montre a dirigé
les particules radioactives vers le nord
ouest c'est à dire vers la suède la
norvège et la finlande
en europe les masses d'air humides des
perturbations dues à la dépression du
golfe de gènes étaient bloqués par les
hautes pressions
situé en france ça c'était la situation
début de semaine mais cette situation
évolue sur cette photo sur la photo que
vous allez voir dans quelques instants
sept photos infrarouges prise ce matin à
5 heures par le satellites meteosat on
se rend compte que l'anticyclone est en
train de se déplacer vers le nord-est et
c'est là que réside le risque les masses
d'air tournant toujours dans le sens des
aiguilles d'une montre
on peut craindre des retours d'est d'air
chargées de radioactivité heureusement
en ce moment les vents sont faibles
voire nulles en certains endroits ce qui
veut dire et ça c'est une chance pour
nous que l'air pollué n'avance que très
très lentement